biology is changing gears reductionist
ma
by systems models based on massive
amounts of data by integrating different
data dimensions we can model complex
phenotypes such as type 2 diabetes we
can place disease genes in biological
context which will help us to identify
the best points for assessing disease
risk and for therapeutic intervention
however biologists are generating data
on a scale that is outpacing our ability
to perform even the simplest of analyses
sequencing flow cell and imaging data
are all growing at phenomenal rates
analyzing those data and integrating
them to form a more complete picture of
biology will require access to large
scale and affordable computing I am dr.
Eric Schadt chief scientific officer of
Pacific Biosciences located in Menlo
Park California
in the following presentation I provide
an overview of high performance
computing tools now available to
biologists in particular we will look at
recent advances such as cloud and
heterogeneous computing these tools will
allow even individual researchers to
assemble the computer power needed to
carry out Big Data biology but first
let's look at the type of computational
challenges currently facing big data
biologists as an example let's imagine a
genetics lab trying to identify genes
involved in the progression of type 2
diabetes
they will genotype a million snips in
sequence RNA for several thousand
individuals with type 2 diabetes plus
experimental controls in this scenario
each individual generates about 3 Giga
bases of sequence information and a
million snip data points this leads to
tens or even hundreds of gigabytes of
raw data the problem occurs once the
researchers wish to integrate their
information about DNA and RNA variation
into a network a Bayesian network for
example shows how genes may causally
relate to one another to produce the
type 2 diabetes phenotype and this is
where they encounter a computational
bottleneck for only three or four genes
the number of possible networks would be
trivial but with even ten genes the
number of possible networks skyrockets
to ten to the eighteenth power as
networks grow bigger the computational
power needed to tackle these analyses
grows exponentially the resulting long
compute
Layton sees can severely slow down
research until recently researchers
would tackle this problem by using
application or storage servers with
extra processing power and random access
memory these servers can be chained
together to form a super computing
cluster this allows the integration of
large-scale datasets comprised of
hundreds or even thousands of variables
however over the past several years two
major innovations have provided
scientists with more effective and
cost-efficient methods for
high-performance computing the first is
cloud computing which is a flexible
configuration of computer cores and
associated storage it is useful for big
data biology as researchers can host
large shared datasets in various public
clouds this makes the data and
computational resources available to a
wide range of researchers similar
approaches are already being used by
particle physicists in addition service
providers like Amazon Google and
Microsoft now offer convenient access to
cloud computing resources microsoft says
your resource will offer 20 million CPU
hours and 200 terabytes of storage over
the next three years via a partnership
with NSF many applications can benefit
from cloud based computing resources
these include searching a protein
sequence against a non-redundant protein
database reconstructing bayesian
networks and predicting interactions
between small molecules and proteins the
architectural features of cloud
computing are also highlighted here the
second innovation is heterogeneous
computing many heterogeneous systems
utilize a graphical processing unit or
GPU which works alongside the general
processor or CPU and standard desktop or
even laptop computers the GPU is
designed to accelerate common
mathematical operations standard in
video games but can also be used for
general-purpose computing this
specialized processor can drastically
improve the throughput of a single
desktop computer as with cloud computing
several important biological problems
have been solved using heterogeneous
computing systems bayesian network
learning protein folding and blast
searches for example have realized a
several full
or more increase in performance and cost
efficiency cloud and heterogeneous
computing are exploding in popularity
and they give researchers access to
processing power that rivals
custom-built clusters the remainder of
this presentation introduces these
computer systems and how they are used
if you're a researcher in the life
sciences facing a Mount Everest of data
the following information will allow you
to compete with the more computationally
savvy groups in the cloud computing
model adopted by Amazon Rackspace and
Microsoft the user can create many
instances of a virtual machine on the
providers infrastructure the user is
charged on a per CPU hour basis the
startup cost is negligible and computing
power is assembled as needed in one case
a group led by Ben Langmead set up a
virtual machine on Amazon's elastic
compute cloud to identify snips among
2.7 billion DNA sequence reads from a
single individual the analysis took 3
hours using 40 CPUs the equivalent of
320 computer cores and costs only 85 US
dollars the trade-off with cloud
computing is control the user has less
control over the underlying hardware and
how the computation is distributed
versus cluster computing recall that
these systems were designed for serving
many independent website requests not
for communication intensive tasks such
as the simulation of many interacting
molecules such applications may be
better suited for traditional clusters
or should be modified to use the more
decoupled cloud resources however cloud
computing offers more control than grid
computing in which computation is
distributed to computers owned by others
who choose to make their systems
available for a particular application
in contrast cloud nodes are typically in
the same data center and share access to
the same network attached storage
thus internode communication is faster
and more reliable the user can also
configure the virtual machine image
including the operating system that best
meets their needs several cloud
providers are now in service I've
already mentioned Amazon Rackspace and
Microsoft's as
or platform these provide the basic
infrastructure for cloud computing other
services like NEX bio and Saito Bank
provide access to analysis tools that
make use of cloud-based resources and
make the results available to other
scientists heterogeneous computational
systems use specialized hardware like
graphical processing units or GPUs
working alongside a traditional CPU GPUs
increased speed because they keep many
thousands of operations in flight in
parallel across hundreds of processing
units in contrast a modern quad-core CPU
which is optimized for latency not
throughput has orders of magnitude fewer
operations in flight at any given time
across just tens of processing units to
use the GPU the programmer rates a
custom version of their application
during execution the necessary data is
copied to the GPUs private memory the
GPU specific functions are invoked and
then the results copied back to the CPU
GPUs are optimized for applications that
apply a small set of mathematical
operations too many data elements in
parallel the greatest benefit is for
applications where the time required to
carry out the operations on each piece
of data is far greater than the time it
takes to copy the data from the CPU to
the GPU for processing the most common
heterogeneous systems are GPU based the
two main GPU providers are AMD and
NVIDIA these cards are typically added
to local computers but are also becoming
available from specialty cloud providers
the folding at home project is a
successful scientific user of
heterogeneous systems and has published
extensively about their experiences
working with this hardware cloud grid
and heterogeneous systems change the
cost capability trade-off even small
labs can now assemble supercomputer
scale capabilities that is systems
capable of performing many trillions of
mathematical operations per second
clouds such as Amazon Elastic Compute 2
are priced on a pay-as-you-go basis
users can assemble the throughput they
need when they need it with minimal
upfront
cost GPUs can deliver several fold or
more increase in throughput for a few
hundred dollars per node much less than
the thousands of dollars that several
additional CPU nodes would cost choosing
among these various systems might seem
daunting but it really boils down to a
few key questions first how much
processing do you want to carry out in
parallel second where is your data
located more specifically will your
application benefit from fine grained
parallelism or coarse grained
parallelism for example searching a set
of sequences against a database such as
blast requires a more coarse grained
parallelism and so the search would be
best carried out on a note of a cluster
or in the cloud however it's important
to note that cloud and heterogeneous
technologies are not mutually exclusive
individual nodes in the cloud can be GPU
based as opposed to CPU based now let's
address several frequently asked
questions about cloud computing first
how is data security handled in the
cloud virtual machine instances behave
exactly the same as physical machines it
is up to the user to restrict access to
the machine using firewall and
encryption settings open ports should be
limited to those necessary for function
and all data and communication should be
encrypted
depending on the data sensitivity and
business requirements users should ask
vendors about regulatory compliance data
location and data segregation policies
secondly how is data transfer handled in
the cloud data transfer speeds are
limited by the speed of the internet
connection between the user and the
cloud services as such transferring
large amounts of data is troublesome
amazon offers a fast direct connection
to their elastic compute resource but
data on the terabytes scale must be
loaded onto storage devices and shipped
third does data persist in the cloud
cloud data is stored on a network
storage system the users virtual
machines pull stored data from this
system and rate results there as well
while data placed on or generated by the
virtual machine image only persist for
the life of that instance data on the
network stores
is persistent last what operating
systems can I run on the cloud most of
the popular Linux distributions as well
as Windows servers can run on Amazon's
ec2 or Microsoft's Azure however the
user is responsible for uploading tools
and applications to the virtual machine
on the cloud this concludes our
presentation I am Eric Schadt wishing
you success in implementing these new
tools into your research
you